what sort of feminism should I support
the one that poses you the greatest
challenge as a young feminist I said
some ridiculous things you must have
come across some right plonkers in your
time i' be in a right fer as
well hello I'm Julie bindle and this is
action men a series in which I have
interesting conversations with men that
actually get up off their backsides and
contribute to the work that feminists
are doing to prevent rape domestic
violence and challenge pornography and
the sex trade today I'm speaking with
Michael Conroy Michael set up Men at
Work men at work is an organization that
looks at Macho culture that looks at the
way that boys are encouraged to fight to
compete and to be abusive towards girls
and in later life women Michael many
people think I'm a manher
do you think I'm a manter um if you are
you're not a very good
one this is what's said about feminist
but I think me in particular because I
talk about male violence yeah uh well
male violence is is one of the well it's
probably the biggest problem in the
world um uh and we have to talk about it
women have to talk about it because it's
your experience and men have to talk
about it because it's our experience as
both victims and perpetrators uh whereas
overwhelmingly women are only the
victims not to say they can't be but
overwhelming we have to look at reality
and the reality is that uh male violence
is probably humans problem number one I
agree with you but I'm interested in why
you want to make your life more
difficult because you could Swan through
life man privilege I hate that word but
we all know what we mean but you put
yourself on the front line and you
decide to tackle this massive issue tell
me about the work you do with boys and
with men uh well it's it's dialogue
based I
train uh now I I train teachers and
youth workers and whoever works with
boys and young men as part of their
professional role but also volunteers
and increasingly Foster families as well
which is really interesting and makes a
lot of sense because they spend a lot of
maybe 20 30 years kind of bringing up
young men so it was something that I
would never have imagined at the outset
but makes a lot of sense I've done some
work recently with VAR fostering
agencies and I think we'll be doing more
uh it's essentially to try and give
support to those adults who work with
boys and young men uh to support them in
being confident that they can have
conversations with them about developing
a resilience to negative messaging from
culture whether it's through porn or
through porn and the hinterland of porn
I would include gaming in that to some
extent um because these things kind of
wash across each other and the way the
algorithms work is kind of a it's a it's
like the guardian not isn't it it's a
perfect storm is it it is AB when well
sometimes I teachers or youth workers
what would you say is a typical shift a
15y old boy might put in online gaming
30 40 hours a week maybe more in the
holidays that's more than they spend in
class so you you kind of It kind of
contextualizes that what is in that
whether it's porn or gaming or both or a
kind of a kind of a pornified version of
game you know um what is in it what's
the message about it so the work that I
do is to give those professionals who
know those boys and young men over
time the tools to have challenging
conversations which are non accusatory
and not intended to be inflammatory one
week recently on Monday I was in a very
famous public
school and the day after I was in a pup
referral unit in Lancashire and the day
after I was in the biggest state
secondary in England and every day was
wildly different but they were also
extremely similar right cuz it's what
are we telling our boys what are our
boys being invited to articulate in
culture so on one day when I'm working
with a state school or approve for
example the conversation is about county
lines and misogyny and why they mix what
is it what is it that makes a 14 15 year
old boy vulnerable what is it he doesn't
feel he's got that he should have and
these Notions of what you should have an
entitlement uh are really interesting
because uh some very well-known bad
faith actors on Tik Tok and Instagram
one of whom is uh often in the Press
mentionable yeah Cly
in Romania um he's the expertise there
and you know sadly there is a form of
expertise the ideas are nothing new but
it's appealing to an an induced sense of
grievance SL entitlement in young men
which if is if you're led to believe you
should be there but you're there and
that's where you should be and that's
fine you're going to keep looking up at
it and thinking why am I not there yeah
why have I not got that and and vo is
going well you should have you should
have somebody somebody's stopping you
that's you know then you open up
conversation with the whole incel
nonsence and Madness where your
entitlement is false that's it that's
starting premise you've been fed wrong
information are those boys that have
that sense of entitlement grow into men
that think they're entitled to control
yeah their female partners and if
they're out of control maybe give them a
back Ender every you now and again for
sure if they if they're feeling need to
but the experts of course don't leave
any marks you know they're just it's all
head games isn't it to come back to I
think what what you're asking is is why
it make your life more difficult I think
I'm trying to make it clearer to myself
personally but also because I would feel
pretty ashamed of myself not to be as
active as I possibly could and is that
because you saw something experienced
something was a light bulb moment where
you then couldn't get back from cuz as a
feminist that's what happened to me
something happened I saw something I was
in Yorkshire at the time of the hunt for
the Yorkshire Ripper I was 17 18 when
things dawned on me that my God the
world is full of
misogyny what happened to you it's funny
to mention those murders up in Yorkshire
um because there's a child in Bolton
even though we weren't fully in there
were road blocks and my at the time was
uh checked twice cuz he worked in leads
so it was something that I I felt un un
unusually kind of scared of even as a as
a boy it it was a it was a string
because I was kind of coming to terms
with what men can do I suppose uh and
there were there were locked there's a
whole menagerie of these horrendous
characters out there uh um on the news
and uh in the news packs Etc so on so
just just riffing on really what you
were saying there about that time I
think it was a bit of a wakeup call also
to other men who I I've spoken to of the
similar age that that we kind of
realized what men are capable of in a
sense strange that it should be that man
who's now I'm not going to publicize but
uh uh it it sort of hit home and that's
that's a strange thing to reflect on
that uh but in terms of light bul
moments um no I've not I've I've had
when we were kids we had some we had the
very exciting uh we put strip lighting
in our living room and it didn't really
work so it was always
like this works in this room strip
lighting in your living room whose idea
was that I think it seemed like a good
idea at the time it was about about the
time that kich hit
Bolton so I was spr off anyway uh but it
strip light of the stter M never really
worked so it was like a lot of false
starts so I'm thinking instead of our
light moment it's more like a very like
a mile long strip light that kind of
keeps starting flickering not really
knowing what to do I it reminds me a
little bit of this guy Paulo freier in
Brazil who writes about levels of
consciousness and that's something that
kind of underpins some of the DV
perpetrator work that I do uh in
association with women's a actually up
in Manchester panker trust um and it's
the idea that you don't just suddenly
become conscious you you go through a
process of having an inclan or feeling
uncomfortable retreating from it because
you don't like the discomfort but
knowing that you have to keep going so
it's that kind of two and throw like the
waves on the shore rather than a single
directional linear movement and I think
that uh is a fairly good descriptive
really about the feelings of uh you know
what like loyalty to friendships that
you just can't have anymore
um things you would might have turned
blind ey to in the past or participated
in you just can't or don't because
they're just wrong they just they're not
you anymore they know all that kind of
stuff um but never thinking that there's
a destination that you've arrived at
it's just a constant movement and um
oscillates a little bit well I want to
talk to you a little bit about class and
thinking about stereotypes as well of
anti-sexist or pro- feminist men and I
don't know what term
you would use for yourself but we can
definitely come to
that but when I first came across men
that were telling us that they were
wanting to be part of the women's
Liberation movement do some good
contribute to our
efforts was in the very early 80s and I
was still in my teens at that time I was
in leads I was at a conference against
pornography and violence against
women and the Crash was run by men and
there was some women saying we can't
have men around kids they're not safe
which obviously we know that to be true
but we also know that to be quite quite
an extreme
position effectively what we're saying
is you can never have men around kids so
it seemed to me a very Bleak out look
yeah and then at the same time there
were these men and some of them would
have been genuine but what I picked up
was men posturing yeah doing the child
care helping the women when in fact it
was their job being what we called Nigel
that that was our word that was our name
for for these men and they had at the
time a magazine called Achilles heel it
was full of very middle class men on a
therapeutic Road right yeah in other
words you know my penis resembles a
flower uh my mother was horrible to me
so I'm a kind of faint-hearted victim of
the patriarchy and then the odd one that
would say things like rape is terrible
and his men's responsibility to do
something about it so it was a mishmash
but I found them all to be extremely
middle class yeah and and very bookish
so they'd learned feminism through books
yeah whereas I'd learned feminism
through doing and obviously we're
calling this series action men because
for
me you have no right to claim that
you're part of any political movement
unless you're doing action thinking
isn't
enough tell me what you experienc about
the stereotype you must have come across
some right plonkers in your time doing
the work that you do I've been a right
plonker as well so I have a an a an atom
of sympathy for them um
H yes yes yes I have I've got a red flag
comes up if any man calls himself a
feminist
because but I do know some good men who
have done that and said it in public and
been slighted for it rightly with this
part of me bra rightly but I'm thinking
what's what now though what does the
after care what can I do so I try how do
we keep him on track as well just
because he he's slipped up how do we
still keep him yeah cuz I think some of
them come to it from the point that
feminism isn't a dirty word it's a good
thing therefore I should support it
therefore I'm going to put my name to it
and not have the thought process of
actually whose is this thing so it's not
ours and I think if any if any men are
watching this who are in that space I
would just um put it this way really
is if we cannot hear the women who say
feminism is ours and it's not yours then
if we continue to say that I am that or
I'm part of it then that is an
aggressive act an abusive act so that's
one thing and I grapple with this all
the time because of course the other
side of that is the genuine man who uses
language that irritates some women but
it doesn't mean we then cut our ties or
condemn him to the point of where he's
out of the movement as a young feminist
I said some ridiculous things and I
wasn't cast aunder um and I stayed in
the movement because we support each
other and what does it matter it it's
you know sometimes it's a word sometimes
it's an attitude which is more
problematic yeah but here's the thing
that I I want to know from a man that
does this
work how do
you distinguish between actual feminists
those that are
genuinely working to end patriarchy end
male violence liberate women and live in
a truly egalitarian society and I would
put myself in that
camp and those
absolute
plonkers that masquerade as feminists it
used to be that no one wanted to be
called a feminist and now everybody
claims it but they're saying for example
Beyonce is a feminist because she's a
strong woman and she's done well for
herself or someone's a feminist because
they fight for the rights of women to do
sex work and stripping or someone's a
real feminist because they speak for all
women including women with penises so
trans women how when you're actually
amongst women and we're saying to you
Michael for God's sake help us out with
this project there's these BLS that
really need talking to there's these
boys that really need educating about
porn you know that's that's cool yeah
but what about those that call
themselves feminists and you know
they're anything but how do you deal
with them uh wow that's a really good
question obviously it's extremely
politically vexed if I can slightly
reframe it I hopefully Answer In The
Same by doing so but if I don't then do
told me
um I've seen a couple of conversations
with men and I've had conversations with
men occasionally behind the scenes
medication meet uh it's football and
fighting and beer and things like that
yeah where you going to get your next
tattoo exactly yeah that kind of stuff
but we do occasionally you know guys in
Australia or Canada we might just
occasionally have have have meet meet up
and a couple of hours and say you know
what's the best way we can contribute to
this what we seeing that's really going
wrong with men who we thought were on
side
um Etc and I guess the question is and I
have seen it posed clearly on Twitter
for example or X whatever it's called
what sort of feminism should I
support answer the one that poses you
the greatest
challenge avoid the ones that don't
challenge you at all avoid the ones that
say that whatever you're doing is
fine because you're part of some bogus
empowerment or liberation so if you're
being told by women and women are
exposed to misogyny as are men and
internalize it in different ways because
you have a different subjectivity within
that that kind of overwhelming
Paradigm uh women do sometimes say but
com occasionally I've made comments
around prostitution and pimp pin online
or in public and they say who are you as
a man to tell me that I can't do that I
said I'm not telling you anything never
would never will never have I'm saying
to my brothers that if you buy women
you're abusing them that's it that's the
end of the story uh and if you choose to
offer as some kind of uh reason or
justification for that that's some women
whose life story and the pressures
within which we will never know lead
them to say that in public or to you
then that's your fault that's your
accountability often I say to the the
young men who I've been working with
over the years why and Men uh adult men
who are work with now I start it by say
why do people believe
things it's part of the reason we
believe things because they suit us and
they please us and they are in alignment
with our habits and our thoughts and
behaviors too right I mean tell me a bit
about yourself in your political
allegiances if you have any describe
your position in the world
and tell us also about what led you to
the work with boys and with men uh yeah
politically quite Keith but a bit of a
mixed bag um I would say traditionally
from a labor background uh working class
from a little to called horch near
Bolton all family my M was a teacher she
was the first educated uh University
goer in our family um and but you know
two up two downs the typical work Irish
Catholic you know back in the day up up
there in Lish I know har Rich friend of
mine was the murder oh really yes Chris
root I more world is it used to be a a
locomotive T and and I used to work at
local works as a cement finisher back in
the day but
um I I find the idea of political
parties absurd I mean I literally I I
couldn't do what's it called cabinet
Collective responsibility I couldn't do
that I I can't get on with reaching that
point yeah I just can't get on with
people I'm trying to be nice but I I
can't possibly say I'm going to agree
with this person I don't know what's
going to come out of their mouth I mean
it just doesn't strike me as saying
however I would say uh broadly uh
socialist
um and yet the people who deliver with
socialism are not always uh the full
ticket well often they're as
misogynistic as the men on the right
just like all hour what do you do what
do you do every day what you say is of
little or no importance to me at all
what do you what your actions where'd
you put your money yeah what where
where' you spend your time and who do
you support do you watch porn do you
watch porn I thought he asking me for a
minute knows the answer to that uh not
that I haven't in the past cuz we're
born into a world where it's everywhere
yeah you know Biz our memories of being
133 14 at a mate's house up in Bolton
and his dad phhs is we just looking at
stuff I'm kind of part thinking what the
hell am I actually looking at what is it
you know is that ex that sex but then
you you don't see it for months maybe or
years or you find a magazine Le is going
back into the S ' 80s and ' 80s like 70s
and ' 80s the old days before
smartphones yeah but you find a magazine
or in a bush bizarre stuff like that but
it was like chance
encounters that and I think something
that people simply don't understand
about qu really is that that world is
like the Jurassic period this is
entirely different it is everywhere it's
within seconds for anybody all the time
and it's now I mean the the porn
magazine Playboy that I found under my
brother's bed in the 70s is now on our
TV screens as just background music yeah
and they've got no idea we we have no
idea in those days when I first started
campaigning against porn even with the
infamous cartoon photograph on the cover
of Hustler magazine of the woman being
pushed through a meat grinder we had no
idea how much worse it was going to get
but tell me how you approach that with
boys because you work with boys and you
work with male perpetrators of domestic
violence don't you let's start on the
boys what did you do with them well that
that stems from I spent 16 years working
in secondary education in in the
Midlands in wers South Birmingham area
uh working across a group of high
schools doing in things around
citizenship community outreach Charities
I was very broad brief I I was given a
lot of latitude which was quite lucky
because I the kind of person who needs
it at work um and I I was allowed to set
up uh boys conversation group support
Works uh for Lads of about 14 15 16 up
to 6 form 17 18 sometimes across a few
schools and supported in that by
teachers and the reason reason for that
was I think it was about 2015
2016 uh we started that was when
smartphones were kind of hitting some of
the kids and then the year after almost
all and then since about 2018 also it's
been everybody but also going into
primary and it just kind of blew
everything into school that had been
there in drips and drops here and there
but it was what happened once a month
was now once a week or once a week is
now every day and instead of just year
10 it's year 8 and seven and we're
hearing about it at primary and it it it
is pornification we're hearing about
horn in primary school yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure yeah no absolutely uh I've
got family teaching primary if you've
got the device the only thing that stops
the only thing between a child and porn
is s guarding aware adults that's all
there is so that you mean adults
understand the actual harm of porn as
opposed to doing that shaming and anti-
seex and humiliating which doesn't work
does it no and which is in fact what
porn is right that kind of orchestrate
humiliation is in a way but it's the the
the parents and teachers parents care as
teachers whatever that kind of Nexus is
the only thing you can't stop a child
accessing the Internet it's just the
genie is out of the bottle it's gone but
all we can do therefore is consciously
have really good conversations with all
parties involved which is safe Guardian
base which is not moralistic or pointy
fingers that doesn't work it's just it's
about the approach whether an approach
works or not because it's very easy to
jump in with both feet and say this is
awful it's terrible and yes it is but
that doesn't work it I mean it doesn't
work and thinking about the way that
kids going through puberty or
approaching puberty are so mixed up
about sex and how girls often and some
boys obviously but so many girls have
their first sexual encounter is unwanted
yeah and then I hear about kids at
school and sometimes girls young girls
like 12 13 14 have come to me where I've
done talks in schools and said things
are happening to them that they're
really unhappy about they don't say rape
they don't use particular words are too
loaded yeah but nobody's actually had
the conversation with them to find out
what's going on at home what's going on
in the schoolyard it's extraordinary
because it's such a huge part of of of
our use it is it is and recent reports
from gosh ofstead everyone's invited the
Neu uh just it seems like a constant
cycle of reports that keep telling us
these things are happening in our
schools and then ofstead the government
tell ofstead to make uh demands of
schools but there's never any resources
or try put in place so there's a uh
sometimes it's almost like why why do we
keep having these reports if there's no
PO if there's no outcome there's no
structural outcome so this is a very
long-winded way to say uh as a result of
the 16 years in Te in teaching and um
certainly the latter eight years up to
say 2020 when I set up Men at Work uh
while I was still working in schools is
because you just look and you think
there is nothing structural programmatic
at all there is ad hoc intervention
after the fact
bandaid damages done spill milk you know
all of that stuff and you thinking this
this is not good enough and I just
started to spend time talking with boys
and young men some of whom I knew uh
were victims of domestic abuse
themselves because they were growing up
in those families their dads are in
prison or or not um usually not of
course usually not for DV but they might
have been for something else but but
dv's in the in the picture and you just
you kind of looking at me thinking well
they've got that they've got porn
they've
got what else about how to how to
develop a compass about how to find
their way in life safely for themselves
and safely for women and girls and other
other Lads around them because it
benefits their lives doesn't it and this
is what I found when I talk to every
single friend of mine in different
countries around the world because as
I've said to you I've got a man in every
port I mean wherever I travel um whether
it's Vancouver or Kenya there's always
at least one male friend doing the work
that you're doing I'll get together with
him we'll have a glass of wine or a cup
of coffee and we'll have a laugh and
that's another thing about the
stereotypes that we're humorous as
feminists and you doing the work as
almost auxiliaries you're humorous and
not only that but you're cow and and you
you you kind of shiver at our feet and
we tell you what to do and you've got no
agency and you don't think for yourself
and so God imagine going out for dinner
with the humous feminist and the cow
fell what a terrible night that would be
but but this is what I hear from men
everywhere is that you do this work with
boys they're getting no positive
messages at all they grew up without a
positive message in the main some of
them are feminist moms or Pro feminist
dads but very few and then you decide to
set up men at work so what is that it
was it's a ultimately it's a training
company for anybody who works with boys
or teenage uh adolescent young adult man
it's one of the wonderful things about
this work apart from it's bad that the
need drives it but you just meet people
and you think how come I don't know
about it how come I didn't know there
was a a young young dad's Outreach group
of nurses in centry doing all this
amazing stuff that that can of vend
diagrams with anti- gang work also you
know and you just I didn't know that no
I know but absolutely and there's so
much good stuff but they wouldn't be
calling themselves part of I'm I'm
feminist they're just doing the work and
that's the thing it's like just do the
work that's it there is no follow on to
that just do it because it needs to be
done and and the kind of waving the flag
and wearing the T-shirt I think is a
sign that you don't really understand
the importance of the work well if you
have to wear a t-shirt to say this is
what a feminist looks like then
seriously you should be locked in a room
for rather a long time with just love
Island and and water shouldn't you yeah
yeah but what's your relationship with
feminists I mean how do you see yourself
in relationship to the women's movement
because it must be a bit fraught
sometimes you're doing this work
sometime you must be viewed with
suspicion sometimes because what bloke
wants to put himself out to do this yeah
I know and that's fine I understand the
suspicion totally and I've made some
wrong moves certainly I I know I've
joined Twitter on 2015 made some very
wrong moves and there you go we all it's
it's all like little insect in Amber
isn't it like it's there um and I think
that's ties back a bit to what you
saying earlier Julie about you were
saying that you'd made some comments in
your early days and later but it yeah
called heaven for fend but um but that
was part of a time which was much more
Humane in that we were allowed to
survive our true
mistakes and now it's just cut and Pace
look [__] screenshot it's like well uh
I'm not going to bother moving on then
if I'm surrounded by you reminding me
what I Redemption what's the point no
understanding no no learning no no it's
so difficult because you understand that
people don't want people to get off
scotf free pretend it never happened but
the other but we've got to have a
trajectory you got to have an arc
otherwise you just close down and keep
anything s it or keep doing the same
thing and anyway there's not enough of
us to be honest that we can afford to
just cut somebody out for the slightest
digression without an understanding I I
love it when I'm able to say oh God yeah
I was so wrong when I said that or that
that article Christ I wish I hadn't read
written that yeah yeah yeah but um let's
move on shall we let's get on with it
and and this is what you do isn't it
because you you I I've seen you say to
some men that are doing good work on
domestic abuse or whatever but that
might have a position that you and I
don't agree with is perhaps on
pornography perhaps on the sex trade in
general Alexandria Dawkin once famously
said you know leftist or Progressive men
as it'd be called now can't have their
pornography and their reputation as Pro
feminist men they just can't no and and
I've seen you challenge other men in a
way that does actually allow things to
move on does allow for a relationship to
keep going surely that's what we need to
I used to be much
less forgiving of myself and others but
no no we can't do that I I do try to be
um and in in real life I not that
Twitter isn't everything is real life
but in the Physical Realm uh I I TR I
try to treat others as I would like them
to treat me I've been treated really
kindly by people who saying mate you got
that totally wrong and I've sat down I
thought [__] I've really got that
totally
wrong okay thanks
I didn't get it and now I I get it or I
kind of understand why why you said that
so I kind of try and reciprocate and
that's going to be an ongoing process I
think but um I was researching the harms
of the sex trade in South Africa it's
mainly it's black um and women of color
girls that are affected by it and it's
not all but mainly white wealthier men
perpetrating these abuses and I Was
preparing for a trip and I had a fixer
somebody who was local who could show me
around and look after me and you know
it's usual journalistic practice a black
woman feminist and she said to me
whatever you do don't stay in the black
areas go to stay in one of the white
bnbs um there too much cry around there
you'll be hassled you'll be bothered and
I took that advice went to stay in the
white B&B found that they were racist
they really were they had a pool boy as
they called him they would make comments
I felt really uncomfortable and at the
end of that trip I thought why did I
just allow myself to take that easy
advice off my fixer who was clearly just
seeing white woman could afford to stay
in the white area yeah and she was doing
that because that's not normally what
journalists would do and I thought why
did I just take the easy way out it was
such a wrong decision and that that
really struck me actually and when we've
done it all the best we can do is try to
learn from anything isn't it really just
there is but we also have to have a
laugh at the same time I mean you know I
can't bear IR I can't bear those
reverential kind of overly
Earnest people that just think that you
have to take a particular perfect line
on everything I call women birds for a
laugh for a laugh you I'll make jokes
that come directly out of sexism
sometimes you'll see people looking at
you as if to say but you're a feminist
how can you talk that's I think probably
why we get on because we're a bit more
relaxed about stuff that isn't perhaps
lifethreatening yeah but just I'm not
that you'd laugh about being saying
Birds I know you would I know you
wouldn't that my secret standup routine
is is to remain secret the burned
burnard man in homage uh no I I I think
um being PA faced is you know it's an
unfor Affliction isn't it really uh but
I wanted to go out for a drink with a
friend of mine um over in Vancouver a
man doing very similar work to you and
he said oh you've got to meet my friend
let's call him Jeff and uh Jeff comes
out says come on boys let's go and get a
really nice Jin martini and Jeff started
telling me about how alcohol was a
patriarchal tool and about how it causes
violence and and I just thought I just
want to go have a martini mate see you
Jeff I really just want to go and have a
drink yeah you know yeah yeah yeah oh
gosh yeah uh but then what the what's
the meaning of that behavior to him I'd
be fascinating I would I would like to
go out for a night with Jeff and I'd
hate to go but I would fascinated kind
of I inter Jeff for this series actually
yeah yeah about his
theory but seriously thank you Michael
cuz um I am so optimistic about actually
boys growing up and becoming men that
are whole human beings and you're part
of that so thank you that's the work
thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you